national master james canton iii here
with chess.com
and today we have game of the day with
the white pieces we have stockfish
and with the black pieces we have leela
chess zero
let's get right into it here we go we
have d4 and d5
classical stuff let's see which one
we're getting c4 and e6 queens gambit
declined here
did not take the gambit so knight to c3
and knight to f6
after knight f6 knight f3 still
following main line theory here you have
a lot of moves
and leela chess zero chooses c6 going
for a semi-slob
variation a hybrid a little bit of
aggressive a little bit of positional
a little bit of everything and after c6
bishop g5 following
mainline theory here after d-take c4 we
are now entering
sort of a botvenic variation of the
semi-slop defense here
and of course the accepted variation
where we're going to see b5
you may see a6 you may see c5 eventually
putting the bishop on b7
and casting queen side is usually the
plan for black after detail c4 so we
play e4
still following mainline theory
attacking the pawn here and also
threatening e5
b5 defends it and usually and sometimes
with these queens gambit
declines or sometimes even the
acceptance you'll have problems
with this diagonal here when you play b5
but you actually don't have that
because there's a knight on f3 blocking
that so after b5 e5
still following exactly what the book
says here e5 attacking the knight
now there's things called ests or equal
or stronger threats which means
just because i'm attacked does not mean
i have to move in and of course moving
it
would be a fatal fatal blunder no matter
where you move this knight of course e4
is losing but knight d5 is losing as
well
as your your queen's hanging so you have
to attack so how do you attack
h6 either back it up or or do something
with it
and we're we're looking for an unbalance
and an imbalance here as black here
to try to keep things in our favor h6
and bishop to h4
one of the main line moves which you'll
see g5 which is still
following book here this position has
been reached thousands of times
thousands um from all levels after g5
knight takes g5 which is a very strong
move here of course again the best
defense being offense
captured the pawn so what and after
takes bishop takes
and now we still keep the pin for the
win
now here the main move is knight b to d7
and what you're going to see is usually
bishop b7 queen c7 a lot
and casting queen side and it becomes
extremely sharp
extremely sharp here after knight b to
d7 you can already see that this is
extremely sharp already
it's crazy stuff going on double pawns
over here but then you have the
the majority and then maybe you'll go
this way it's a lot going on
but after knight b to d7 there's this g3
move so to try to oppose
this whole diagonal especially if our
bishop's gonna sit here on b7
it's a very strategical like move
playing g3 and here you usually do see
bishop to b7 or queen c7
you also have queen b6 these are usual
moves but in fact
lilith chad zero chose something that
usually is not played here very
interesting move in fact
here it is right here rook h5 now it's
still equal all around the board here
but rick hribe is definitely an
aggressive move just saying hey i want
to attack this bishop
throw you off a little bit because i'm
sure you were expecting queen c7
or queen b6 or bishop to b7 but i play
rick h5 which is completely different
so after rick h5 it does hit the bishop
stockfish chooses to actually capture on
f6 with the bishop here
we capture back of course we need to
keep material count even they take and
we could play queen f6
but your rook's hanging you know black
with your face this is a family channel
so let's go rook f5 and get out of the
way and attack this pawn on f6
then bishop h3 we develop with tempo
here so we're attacking the rook
goes to f6 and we've made three rook
moves already
sometimes that could be bad sometimes i
can come back to bite you
castle and bishop to b7 and now in this
move it's white to move what would you
actually do how do you proceed here you
do have moves like 94 which i'm assuming
you you'd probably play it now
maybe work to e1 but what else would you
do in this position why to move
here it is actually white shows very
interesting move i actually like this
from stockfish choosing bishop to g2
backing up and saying hey this diagonal
is dead i'm hitting a brick wall
why would i keep my bishop here first
off loose pieces lose games and loose
being undefended
means it could be it could come under
attack somehow if the bishop just sits
on h3
sometimes it could just be attacked and
if we're able to get this queen loose
and help us
somehow some way on this diagonal you
know of course we're playing a little
bit of hope chess here
but we we want to see if we can get this
diagonal or this file
and attack this bishop at the same time
because it is loose it's a loose piece
it's undefended so bishop g2 was a very
strong move
so it's hitting c6 is also opposing the
bishop or even threatening stuff like
knight takes b5
so after after bishop g2 queen b6 which
is a standard move here
and then we're casting queen side
usually now you want to keep the threats
up rookie one wouldn't be as good we
know castling queen side is coming
so white displays 94 hit the rook here
do something with this rook let's see
where you go
rick f5 runs into bishop h3 so rick the
g6
stepping out of the way and here's a
nice move from white here actually just
stepping out of the way
queen h5 how many of you would have
played this move this move is actually
really strong i like it a lot you're
also threatening rook to d1
in many cases and some other tricks up
the sleeve queen h5
castle queen side following usual lines
usual theory usual variations and
positions
that you see here in this sort of
semi-slav
castle queen side and you could play
rook d1 but this pawn is hanging
no matter what so whether you play rook
d1 or not this pawn is hanging so in
fact
what would you do white to move here not
the easiest and a complicated position
but what would you do here it is nice c5
strong move actually threatening stuff
like knight takes e6 in certain cases
now bishop g7 stepping out of the way
let's just put some extra pressure here
even rook h8 and we feeling real great
bishop g7 and here it is white
to move your move guys it's finally time
to do
something it feels like our pieces are
placed pretty nicely besides the rooks
what do we do do we move a rook do we
move the bishop
maybe moving the king prophylactically
but that seems like that could be wrong
what would you do in this position
here it is i hope you was thinking about
forcing moves first because you always
should be
knight takes e6 and we in the mix oh my
goodness
if pawn takes queen takes g6 that's not
a move big fella
so rook takes e6 would be a move and
after rook takes c6 you actually have
queen takes f7
attacking the rook and the bishop at the
same time so you actually get that
material back and
you're also doing well i mean you have
three past pawns not one
not two three past pawns on the side of
the board
this is going to be crazy amarox are
going to win win our material back as
well
so after knight takes e6 powerful move
and rook h.a of course allele chess was
already
anticipating this rick hey so you need
to be very careful where do you put this
queen queen g4 doesn't make any sense
queen f3 just drops a piece what are you
doing with your life
right maybe queen f3 i guess you may
know no they've done work pawn takes so
that doesn't work queen of three we were
thinking rook takes but just pawn takes
and you're fine
so actually queen f5 is the best move
here keeping the pressure
uh discovery over here if pawn takes we
do have queen takes and if rook takes
again queen takes f7
so rook f6 hitting the queen once again
and then we go back
queen g4 cool we're good eating g7 now
we have a discovery
rook to g6 and now we take do we sack
the queen
no we just block with a check by the way
gaining a tempo which is extra time
and in king to b8 the king loves to be
on b8 usually
you when you cast the queen side it's
you your castle is not usually finished
until you move your king to the b file
so you can get off of uh the trouble
that can happen on the c file via x-ray
or etc because of your king being on the
c file so king b8
now we have to keep the attacks up one
thing you notice about the engine play
and about just play period especially
from strong players is the attack rate
like how much do they attack
how much do they do counter attacks when
they are attacked how much do they
implement the best defense being offense
right you want to pay attention to that
so after kingdom b8 there's bishop
before attacking the rook and queen
takes d4
again best defense being offense you
take my rook i take your queen very
simple
very simple so what does white do what
does i do
i can how do i get out of this pin like
i can move my queen
i could move the bishop and try to trade
but that actually drops a piece
but very simple right bring rooks to the
file with a smile
rook a to d1 absolutely appreciate it
thanks for the free tempo here
and now after f5 which was really strong
by the way
really strong because if you take with
the bishop we're going to have some
trouble we're actually going to lose the
g5 knight
so we had to take with the queen here
queen takes f5 hitting the rook twice
hitting the rook twice here and again
another equal a stronger threat this
move right here is like
nuts rook f6 that is a insane move
if you take my queen i take yours i'm
also hitting your rook and i'm hitting
your knight now
so in fact i'm basically winning if you
take on
d4 that is not a move in fact of course
stockfish saw this already
and play queen to g4 and shut the door
i'm feeling good out here
queen takes b2 from legochest 0 and says
i'm gonna take everything i can get from
you but you need to be aggressive
if someone's taking pawns from you if
you feel like the position is open
you feel like you have coordination good
pieces good development you got to keep
attacking
96 beautiful move hitting the bishop on
g7 bishop h6
followed by rooks to the seventh rook to
d7 put rooks on the seventh rank
you should not allow this says my system
from aaron nimswitch you should not
allow rooks on the seventh or the second
rank
because it's just going to be decisive
results even being down material so
after rook to d7
bishop to ca you have to get out of here
my guy
you can't stay here long this rook has
to go and knight to d8
so let's go back here again and look at
this move i mean
first off i'm in trouble you would
probably think rookie seven and i want
you guys to get in the habit
of thinking of equally stronger threats
really strong moves
thinking outside the box and calculating
a little bit further
knight to d8 is a very strong move here
threatening knight takes c6
defending my rook at the same time and
rook takes
actually is a fatal error because you
actually pin yourself thinking that you
were pinned oh i'm pinning him
but you're actually pinning yourself so
it doesn't work
knight d8 and we great knight d a big
boy move and then after queen to e5
well what we have to do is we have to
take something there's so much going on
this knight feels like he's hanging do
we double there's a pawn on c6 like
there's so much stuff going on here
that it's insane so after the queen e5
move there's actually knight takes c6
attacking the queen with check of course
and rook takes and bishop takes
and then we have c3 now i could take the
rook here but queen takes could be
decisive
maybe maybe not of course you have queen
c7 i think white's pushing for a little
bit more here as you see we're up uh at
least a pawn here so
now c3 we're trying to push this past
pawn trying to queen
did you thought this was crazy guys wait
to the next few moves okay
bishop takes b5 so this is a very strong
move very very strong now of course
queen takes b5
runs into some very nasty stuff well
let's see it why
wing takes b5 wait a second can i just
win the queen well you actually can't
rook b1 and you're done that's not a
move
so you can't do that at all your queen
is pinned so like what do you do you
don't even have a check you can't even
check him
so it feels like that was a blunder but
in fact it's actually not
you have to remember loose pieces lose
games and what does loose mean
loose means undefended so let's see what
undefended pieces we got
well this is defended this is undefended
the queen's kind of undefended she
defends herself in a way but definitely
this rook's undefendant so here's the
move queen d4
hitting the rook and mate at the same
time
you take i take or actually check first
and then i can play rook b1 in between
moves attacking b8
and then captures and take on a on h6
and we're just winning
c2 when we play rook c1 and we have this
whole thing covered
you're not queening if you wanted to
you're never getting a queen there
so with that being said that didn't
happen queen takes b5 was not the move
in fact
c2 was played and says i'm about to
queen you know what just forget it
let's just queen and just keep it moving
now after after that happens queen to
before threatening all kind of
checkmates and nastiness here queen it
before what a move
bishop takes d7 we gotta get rid of
something there is no mate here
yet you know we're trying to but and
this is a strong move here look at this
bishop c6
check you had this check you had this
check but he finds this check stockfish
was very strong for finding this check
strong period but anywhere the king goes
you have queen b7 check
if you go king c8 you're actually
getting made it so king c7 is the best
move
and the queen b7 check hitting the king
if you go to d8 maiden we great to start
a new game so king to d6
now the king is out in the middle of the
street what a game
take stock of the position and realize
white
the black king looks like he's about to
get made it somehow and but also black's
about to queen and have
two extra two queens on the board so one
extra queen
this is nuts how does white proceed well
actually
very strange not strange but very
interesting move which is bishop g2
backing all the way up allowing this to
happen to us here
now what happens if a queen happens well
if queen happens you're in a lot of
trouble actually after rook takes
bishop takes c1 and then queen c6 check
king d4 and you actually take on c1 with
winning chances here for white believe
it or not just because the king's in the
center of the board
you also could if you trade queens if
the queens do actually come off
well you do have these extra pawns here
that could easily win the game these are
three past pawns not one not two but
three
past ons so this usually nine times out
of ten we'll be winning in many
situations
so there was no queen there in fact
after bishop g2 there was king b4 just
stepping out of the way
trying to make this thing worse because
we can block with the queen
if we have checks there is no rook the
rook can't actually help us
the queen's the only thing that can
check us so king b4 queen b7 check
obvious queen b5 defending and now in
this position
white to move what can you do here what
would you do
what would you do in this position i'm
sure you're probably going to check
maybe not trading queens because queen
is going to happen and then you would
lose in that case
so why to move which check are you going
to do because you know it's going to be
a check here why to move
here it is instead of queen to e7 a3
check
very nice hey if you take i'm going to
take this is called a diversion
right and then king to a4 runs into
bishop c6
king c5 loses the queen so king c4 is
the only move we would love to get
bishop f1 in but unfortunately we don't
have it and our queen's not hanging but
where we don't want to trade
so we check him again queen f7 check in
d4 running to the center of the board
king's in the middle of the street but
luckily defending right now luckily
defending
now this move sometimes you need quiet
moves which is very hard i did just give
you a hint here but sometimes you need
quiet moves to help you finish this
or quiet connectors is what they'll call
that meaning yeah it's a smaller move
it's not allowed to move like a check
checks are loud moves you know with a
quiet move here so i gave you a hint
what do you think the quiet move is why
to move
here it is stockfish chose rookie one
says oh you about to be done
ricky won well let's see what happens on
the queen because the queen is like yo
just queen
how many of you would just queen here
right so after after the queen happens
we have actually a very nice check which
we had already
queen f6 and king to d3 which you also
have two moves we're going to run
through both if king d3 then we're going
to take first and then come back and get
the other one
yeah you got two queens i'll take both
if you don't mind
so gg so king c5 is actually the better
move here
after rook takes then bishop takes you
actually take the rook this is just a
super winning end game here
no checks for black and we're about to
queen one of the three if not all of the
three pawns here we have
so that doesn't work at all in fact
actually after king to oh we already
looked at this one
yeah bishop f1 and you're done there so
after rookie one bish
uh rook two f eight attacking the queen
here queen is still happening
what a nuts game this is insane this is
literally insane after rick f8
queen to g6 hitting c2 now again
again there is an option to queen but
this is not what happened but let's
check and see what happens if queen
happened
if queens which is most likely what most
humans would do
we take the queen bishop takes and queen
d6 same
same situation the same variation in a
way where we're just grabbing the rook
and gonna win this and convert this by
means of queening the three pawns we
have extra so
now after that after that it was
actually rook to e8 queen to g6
rook e8 very strong move by the way that
was pretty sweet
just because if you take this rook now i
get the queen with no
problems so there was no capture in fact
there was a check
just to see where the king goes we're
gonna just see where you go
first queen f6 check king to c4 bishop
f1 is a very strong move but
i mean it's one of the three moves in
this position you actually have rook a1
and rook to c1 rook a1 is definitely
engine like
definitely engine like and what do you
think stockfish play right here
rook a1 okay rook a1 how many of you
guys would have played
that move rook a1 that's nuts there rook
a1
rook c1 was also another one which was
kind of strange because it is a
capture but rick a1 and bishop f1 is
coming so
rick a1 happened queen to b6 out of the
way and bishop f1 check anyway there is
no queen behind it anymore
king to b3 it looks like this king is
getting mated
but weirdly enough it's just not being
made it just yet
queen f7 and rook to see uh rook to e6
here
so he's already in trouble black is in
some trouble here so after rookie six
what do you do guys
it's your move can you finish this is it
winning is it losing is it a draw what
do you do right to move
sockfish chose ricky one rookie one put
pressure on the pin piece we learned
that from chess kids
ricky won and then c1 with the queen now
we finally clean this
okay finally queen is and now what do
you do man
what are you gonna do guys you're gonna
take this queen right rook takes c1
you taking the queen is that a yes
you're taking this queen
rick takes c1 nope rook takes e6
flex real hard oh my goodness what is
going on there's two queens on the board
there is sorry three total but two of
them
are not mine okay says white rook takes
e6 saying hey
i don't care what you're gonna do i'm
getting one of those queens back
and i also gotta work in the in the
process
what a move here in fact white's just
crushing now
rook takes e6 how many of you would have
taken with the queen raise your hand i
know it's okay
it's okay when you find a good move you
look for a better one okay
so rook takes e6 man that's a big boy
move here unbelievable look at that
let's finish this out queen b to c5 and
then rook b6
double check so you have to move your
king king to c3
and then queen to f6 check kind of a
ladder in a way
king to d2 oh thank you appreciate it
thanks for the generosity queen takes h6
check two queens still on the board
for black king to d1 and then queen to
e6
bro what we need six who does this
oh stockfish does queen e6 what happens
if you take one of the or not one of
them
if you take the rook either way it's
mate on e2
oh my goodness wow what a move queen e6
that's scary that'd have you thinking
right there queen 1 to c2
saying hey no mates today my guy no
mates and then rook d six
check so we have to try to tuck the king
and we're feeling kind of safe
well i'm kind of saying we got two
queens this is a strange position
my king has no shelter really i'm like
in the middle of the street
but i got two queens though i got two
queens king c1 and queenie one check
okay cool i can't go queen d1 i'm only
forced to go here and
oh thanks bro give me that queen back
it's time to get that back let me
let me get one of those back from you
rook to d2 queen c3 and that's a wrap
rook takes king takes and this is over i
could just take the queen
right now we can take c3 is just
straight up winning
but of course the engine likes to do
things with the utmost accuracy
so queenie two check was actually the
move but queen takes c3 as a human this
is just winning but queen e2 check
king b3 and then we play h4 king takes
a3 and then he trades queens which is
sort of strange
but as you know the engines make strange
moves sometimes but still stronger than
all of us
queen e3 queen takes takes king b4 and
this is easy let's just run through this
h5
and we live i mean this is over queen a1
or h8 a queening
and then uh king to c5 queen d4 check i
mean this is this is clockwork bishop a6
what a move
just cutting off some squares like
finding the fastest way to make
engines will always find that king c7 e4
king b8
queen b6 one move left king a8
and you do this when you do the honors
you do the honors
that's right queen b7 mate and we great
what
a game that was wow you knew it was
going to be sharp but
wow we didn't know it was going to be
that sharp two queens on the board
king in the middle of the street what's
going to happen that was nuts but i hope
you learned something today from this
wild game
i'm national master james canty iii here
with chess.com and i'll see you guys
on the next video